welcome to another episode of don't get
forked oh my name is Ryan I'm the club
manager here and this show is about
showing puzzles that all involve Forks
we have contestants come up a lot of
employees and club members will come up
they'll look at a puzzle and try to
figure out how the best way to not get
forked and just so there's no confusion
about what a fork is a fork is one one
piece attacks two other pieces any piece
can fork so all of our puzzles are
supplied by international Messer Eric
Rosen so thank you very much for that
and let's go to the board welcome back
to the next round of don't get forked
with us today is a longtime Chess Club
associate Ben Simon Ben welcome yeah
hello bet you know the rules of don't
get fork
I've heard some rumblings Blaine it to
me please so in three in a couple
seconds I'm gonna tell you to turn
around look at the board yeah White has
the best move to make that involves not
getting for it alright so you're gonna
move it on the board and you're trying
to figure out where to move that allows
you to not get forked and is the very
best move on the board there might be
moves on the board that are good that
don't get forked but they're not the
best are you ready I think so okay three
two one go
okay right here has a king a bishop and
rook black has a queen and the king is
White's turn to move and you now have
three seconds
lots of options lots of places the
bishop can go there bro can go have to
figure out the best one in 11 seconds I
need you to move it on the board don't
get forked all right get down two
seconds to Ben Simon has figured out the
best move on the board with me - all
right thanks I have an excellent job you
get it fork so now let's say black makes
the best move on the board here which is
obviously Queen to g3 check what do you
do here you know it looks like I'm
running the bishop no no no no
definitely not I'm gonna I'm gonna go
right here and get out of the check with
a check of my own ah yes excellent all
right thank you very much
alright thanks for joining us on don't
get for it please like share and
subscribe to all our videos and if you
have any good fork puzzles please send
them to info at st. Louis chess club org
thanks